a writer who made a particular
impression on young Arthur Schlessinger
was Apes rider Haggard who wrote King
Solomon's Mines author quoted some lines
from the book in his memoir and made it
very clear that he wanted them read on
this occasion out of the dark he came in
like a storm driven bird at night we fly
out of the nowhere for a moment our
wings are seen in the light of the fire
and lo we are gone again into the know
where life is nothing life is all it is
the hand with which we held off death it
is the glowworm that shines in the night
time and is black in the morning it is
the white breath of the oxen in winter
it is the little shadow that runs across
the grass and loses itself at sunset
Alexandra members of the family ladies
and gentlemen I am here in two
capacities first it would be
historically unjust unless someone
showed up to defend the imperial
presidency
second add more seriously I am here to
represent the other half of Ted
Sorensen's moving one-word description
of arthur schlesinger as a great teacher
for I knew him first only as a student I
was not part of the Kennedy
administration or the Harvard faculty or
any other of the vast circles of
influence simply a young man reading
books about Andrew Jackson and Franklin
Roosevelt a thousand days and Robert
Kennedy and his time then I read about
him the historian the public servant the
progressive partisan later I even dug up
a copy of the vital center I had finally
found the 1960 campaign book but which I
wish to say more in a moment when he
wrote that book that got him in so much
trouble about what the meaning of
multiculturalism was Hillary and I had
one heck of a fight about that and
if she were not running for office I
would tell you who was on which side
I was amazed when I read the cycles of
history because it captured I think
something we all sort of all of us who
have thrown ourselves against the rocks
of public endeavors that never seemed to
yield felt and I thought more of people
who fought against those cycles whether
they won or lost Adlai Stevenson and Al
Gore and John Kerry and all the other
people who were not that much different
than those who won and fought against
the cycles until a better day arrived
I liked war in the American presidency
not so much because it was a book with
which I generally agree but because he
Arthur recognized that though he wished
the strong presidency and he loves
strong presidency he was very much in
favor of the Constitution and against
unlimited power by anyone even people
whom he liked admired and supported
after we left after I left office and
moved to New York I got to see Arthur
Moore and I saw him just a couple of
weeks before he passed away I was struck
by how the years had made his body
stronger but his spirit more clearly
emanating from his small frame the fire
in his eyes the drive in his voice the
passion about politics he spent some
time after I left office trying to
convince me to actually write a book for
his American presidency series he wanted
me to do the biography of Lincoln and I
said about our time I got this big
contract with another company and I got
I have to write my memoirs he said yeah
but Lincoln's is a better short story
and shorter
when Abraham Lincoln gave the Cooper
Union speech from this podium American
politics was very different while he
really was the first strong president
since Jackson people didn't campaign
then as they do now this speech made him
president he went home to Illinois and
afterward when people wanted to know
what Lincoln thought about anything they
gave them the Cooper Union speech
thousands upon thousands upon thousands
of copies and the important thing was
first he wrote it himself something
Arthur admired over 7,000 words and
second he was lincoln the representative
of the vital center there were the
people who wanted to dissolve the Union
to get rid of slavery there were the
people who were willing to dissolve the
Union unless they could spread slavery
everywhere then there was the fight over
the vital center between Lincoln and
Douglas Douglas saying well they ought
to have slavery wherever they vote for
it and Lincoln's saying I despise this
but I'll put up with it where it is if
we can hold the Union together that is
the great enterprise the command of the
Constitution it is a brilliant speech
because he sought the vital Center he
understood the cycles of history he
understood both what was possible and
what was limited
that's what Schlesinger did he was
unashamed of being both in the arena and
writing about it
he had a feel for the difficulty of the
political enterprise he loved the
passion of the combatants and he really
believed what he wrote about I just
learned from Ted today apparently and
only a day when he wrote that little
book Kennedy or Nixon does it make a
difference whichever side you're on in
that
battle as it recreates itself over and
over again Arthur Schlessinger knew it
always makes a difference
he liked the progressives more because
he thought that our crowd was more
likely to advance America's eternal
mission to form a more perfect union
because of his nearly 90 years he made a
difference in the Union that Abraham
Lincoln spoke to preserve here is truly
more perfect because he lived